こんにちははじめそうですあの僕オセロめちゃくちゃ弱いんですよ
[音楽]
あんまり自分の家とを見せたくないんですけどせろめちゃくちゃ祝いんですけども
こんなアプリがむなしいですねマッケイられるなら負けてみてくれ
世界最弱のオセロ ai が開発された新しいデー
林兼将棋とかをすると風邪さ曲強いコンピューターと買ったが ai とか出るって話
はよく聞くんですけども
世界最弱のオセロ ai が出たっていうのって聞いたことなくてでいろいろちょっと
見てみたんですけどもあの負けられないらしいんですよ
どうしても僕も良いんですけどどうしても買っちゃうそんなことがあるのかと思ったの
で今回私そんな対策を
スロ ai に曲げてみようと思いますけどもう一杯ジョイてこちらですね
サイン着オセロ菜酒 ai ません次1717スを30様2100はい
72引き分けすげーそれでも1717人買ってる人が居ますねそれでも3032100
入ってんもうこの本の過程で真月はでですねこれ客
に負けてみたいところありますねあなたの番私から行かせていただきます
あ僕黒っぽいですね
まあ負ければいいんでしょでもずっとマルイて売って
[音楽]
この時初めは本当は置いたけどこの ai
がちで弱い切ってるお皿ってこの一番外の格好4発だと有利になったんで
うまいなぁ負ける方法さんが吸ってるぞこの人
まぁこれでどうだ何としても一番外の確保は大きいものです
一番外の取らせれば巻き過ぎ寝る気がする
井山五せろ女強いんですよねほんとに何かをせるとは消費税とかマジで驚くほど弱くて
びっくりしてるんですけど
アラブとっさーんか山田音丸耕
もう悩んでる悩んでるコスピザイド曲げれるぞこれ
いや上手いこと等待ってるてくるとこのカードだけはと続いてない気がするはいどうだ
[音楽]
ヤバイぞなんだどうせ負けたい
扇ここで動くしかないのは追い詰めます1回いっ
山々絶対いく契機にしかないんだよねー
横井テトラ撮っちゃいますかどう
やばいぜ
家族しかない
[音楽]
こっから相手のほう範囲が来るはずなんで
ヤバイかっツアー
他国ことに打って
わーカードじゃあもううーんわー
やっ
[音楽]
あなたの36位しか家
さあこの ai
マジで弱いすごい本当に何が負けようと思って戦ってるんですけどあまりに弱すぎて
買っちゃいますねこれはスゴいぞこれ
設けてみます4次頑張って負けるぞでものも分かるが負けようと思ったことないからね
戦略がわかんないんだよなぁ全絶対間違いなくカードは取っちゃ駄目ですねアド取っ
ちゃうとかっつんねー
んはぁっ
やばいまずで角を取るしかないな
[音楽]
ば現在勝ちましたそりゃ嬉しく
ねこれほんとすげーなやばいよ本当に
外に通う固める作成な口調に気がすんだよ
やべっな普通に買っちゃったなんならパーフェクトバトルだったわまんでなんだよゐ
弱いんスゴイねこれ1717人の
買った人たち混ぜですごい味がペン717人の負けた人たちマジで凄いよなぁこのエア
今津で弱いぞ
やばいやばいやばいまじでやばいなんか自分がついて錯覚してはコレ
[音楽]
ん
負けるかっ発見やこれすごいですよ僕はってほんと苦手なんであの弱いんですけど今
上映からこそ多分
巻き方もわからないんでしょうねちょっともうちょい頑張ってみれば
うん
ん
うーまたせいやバズ本土笑っちゃいが良いんだけど
無理だ何て言えばいいんだろう1回も負けれませんや逆に気持ちいいのかとかよく
わかんないんですけど逆の発想ですね最弱の大瀬良のへ本当に弱いでぜひ挑戦してみて
ください
じゃあんだ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ